[Music]
this is star talk
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and it's a cosmic queries
edition on a subject that i don't know a
damn thing about
blockchain cryptocurrency we've all
heard about it we've seen it and i count
myself among the profound ignorant
that subject so
we have to do a show on it i have a new
co-host oh my gosh
marcia belski marcia welcome to star
talk
thank you so much for having me i'm
excited to be here i am also very
ignorant of cryptocurrency and when
people have tried to explain it i mean
i'm not even good at the basic finance
stuff so this is like next level
this is i'm in i'm in phd and i haven't
gotten my undergrad but
i'm gonna try
actually so you're a stand-up comedian a
musician a writer and
you had a hit song
recently that's just completely
crazy it's just completely it's called
100 tampons we'll get you to explain it
later but with a title song like that
you you know we need we we're going to
need an explanation yes you got it and
it's space related
and space related that's what makes it
even better so let me introduce our
expert here since neither you nor i
marcia carry that uh that expertise we
have got dr sandra johnson
sandra is the founder let me check out
my notes it's founder and ceo of
multiple companies um one uh her day job
currently is
global mobile finance
inc which is a fintech
startup company she's got multiple
degrees in electrical engineering and
has
40 patents is that more than 40 patents
pending is that right or then pending
yes
issued impending okay thanks for that
and you're also a visiting scholar at
north carolina a t sandra johnson
welcome to star talk oh thank you very
much neil it is certainly a pleasure to
to be here i look forward to having some
fun
excellent and um part of your background
takes you through ibm in africa so what
was that
what happened there that is direct well
you know 26 plus years at ibm and after
about i don't know 22 23 years and i was
thinking about uh what i wanted to do
next i actually went on a trip to africa
and had a eureka moment
when i visited a slave castle in ghana
uh and it was through that experience
that you know i i found my purpose and
destiny and that is to
focus on leveraging my technical skills
uh to help the people in africa to raise
their standard of living so i then went
looking for opportunities to do that
with ibm
i ended up
spending three years in the middle east
and africa two years in dubai and one
year in nairobi kenya
but all three years traveling throughout
the middle east and africa primarily
africa
uh
visiting more than 22 countries many of
them several times
and so i was i was the cto of ibm
central east and west africa it sounds
like we can create four other shows
based on your life experience
but we have to like be selective and so
uh right now we're we're going to be
thinking about cryptocurrency we
solicited questions from our eager uh
fan base our
patrons patreon members
and
just tell me um
sandra what got you into cryptocurrency
well i i'm always trying to always uh be
aware of and try to learn about uh
emerging or
leading edge of bleeding edge technology
yes bleeding edge that's the one
so um so a few years ago when blockchain
was just starting out i started uh you
know talking to people about it reading
up about it learning about the technical
details and then it just really took off
in terms of height
right uh and so i sort of rolled the
wave in terms of uh keeping myself
abreast from a knowledge perspective of
of what blockchain uh is all about what
cryptocurrency is all about it even
thought about leveraging it and my
fintech startup as well
so is the first question we audit marcia
and i ought to be asking is what is
blockchain so like we just yes is that
is that the entry level
like kindergarten
preschool question that's what you were
in since the old stuff you've been
listening to them since the old records
like you were in before everybody knew
it was cool
yeah so what is blockchain what is
cryptocurrency what's the difference
between the two yeah let's start there
please okay so so blockchain i i think
of it as the foundation the technology
foundation to uh get things done
uh it is really i'm sure all of us are
familiar with well maybe not all of us
all of us older folks are familiar with
what's called the ledger you think about
a black bank ledger where you input
entries and the ledger and the ledger
what what blockchain is
is you can view it as a distributed
ledger it's an electronic ledger but
it's a distributed ledger
uh and each entry is what's considered
a block
if you will
uh
and that block essentially contains a
list of transactions
okay and so a blockchain is essentially
a chain of blocks which is essentially a
distributed ledger
that if it's public anyone can read
anyone can read anything that was ever
written on that blockchain that that
link of ledgers uh and
once it's placed
on the blockchain it's immutable it
cannot be changed
and so in the essence that's what a
blockchain is
compared to a ledger
so it seems so far from what you
described the only difference is uh
everyone can see it it's unchangeable as
most ledgers really should be right
and
and it's
distributed okay so
so now what anyone in the world can see
it there's no centralized mechanism for
it so that's what i mean by distributed
all right okay so you're removing the
the the banker
right right right in fact you know step
back just a little bit of the history
behind this
um the first block chain was the bitcoin
blockchain which is
bitcoin is a cryptocurrency and i'll
talk about that in a minute
but it was the brainchild of this
individual or group of individuals uh of
uh that we don't know uh they wrote this
white paper the author is uh sakoshi
nakamoto
we don't know who he or she is
at this point
but he wrote this
white paper that is this paper
describing this idea of having a
currency
that's independent of companies you know
and it came right after the recession in
2008 right
so you know it was a financially based
recession so it came up with this idea
how can we come up with this currency
that's independent of let's say a
a central bank
and so that's not what not only
independent of a central bank
independent of a country yes
yes okay yes uh and so that was the
basis for
the bitcoin
blockchain that was then created
in january 2009 so it's been 13 years
right but again it's the foundation it's
a distributed ledger where you put
information about transactions uh that
anyone can access
and uh it's unchangeable okay i have to
check i gotta check with marcia at
intermittent moments here so marcia
have you heard enough yet to be paid in
bitcoin for your stand-up acts i mean
absolutely not but not because i don't
trust it
only because i i'm fascinated first of
all but also i've like never felt more
stupid in my life because i'm realizing
i think i'm at almost and not there are
other people in my generation where this
is probably different but i'm realizing
that i'm in i'm a millennial you know
i'm 32 so i'm in the exact age where i
don't actually really know what a ledger
is they didn't really teach us any
financial literacy
in school i don't really know how
banking works it's always mostly been
like when i was a kid you know i
remember they taught us how to write
checks but like they didn't teach us any
of the deeper stuff and i'm also not gen
z and younger who knows all about the
internet
you know so you're just dangling
you're dangling over the crevasse of it
i'm dangling in the cosmos i'm like but
it's so fascinating to me because i can
see now because people have been long
what i have heard
talking about cryptocurrency as a way
like you said to work outside these
establishments and i that never made any
sense to me but that's i'm starting to
see
how and why that is well we're getting
there but just
to alert sandra what it means is some
people
are not being helped by your analogy to
a ledger
most people probably are because people
my age are probably listening thinking
like no i know what it is she's just an
idiot but okay
okay
i was just checking in i was checking
with marcia make sure we're we're on the
same page okay i'm like the person they
should put in the olympics next to
michael phelps to show how fast he's
actually swimming i'm how dumb people
actually can be on this right so okay
yeah
okay okay so continue so so so so i've
discussed at a high level
the what blockchain is right which is
the foundation right now let's let's
talk about crypto right and i'll use an
example the most
uh
uh successful uh the most popular
cryptocurrency which is bitcoin
all right and so
essentially
without getting to into a whole lot of
gory detail
uh
bitcoin
was created to
incentivize people to add blocks to the
blockchain
every few minutes a new
block is created so how is it created
well you have people that are called
miners
all over the world
all competing to
be the next to have the next block to be
added to the blockchain so they all have
that well these are minors not young
people under age these are minors like
people like coal miners people who are
mining for mining for gold for example
and so around the world they all have
their own blocks that they have locally
and they all compete
to be the next block
in the global chain of blocks okay and
how do they compete well they work at
this very complex cryptographic
algorithm that they use i liken it to
rolling the dice
right and they're all rolling the dice
and and
and one of them
is looking for the double six well
they're all looking for the double six
but the first one to get it is the
winner
okay and the price
is you get your block to be added to the
blockchain but you also get bitcoin
and that's how bitcoins created uh you
get 12 and a half bitcoin initially was
25 bitcoin so now it's 12 and a half you
get 12 and a half bitcoin if you get the
double six
how do you know
how
who
marcia helped me here
so it's all is it all luck
how do you know i mean dice when we
think yes when we think of dice we think
of luck so
so so i don't have this algorithm can i
make my own algorithm and how do i know
if i've landed on the double six they
all
they all uh use the same
cryptographic algorithm is a very
detailed computation
it's an algorithm that's programmed and
they all are looking for a certain
result they all know what that result is
right
uh
but only it's very difficult to get that
that result you know it's double six is
a a lot easier than the it's a number
that they're looking for it's a binary
number
256 256-bit binary number and they're
all uh
calculating this algorithm that will
give them a
256-bit result
how do you know if you hit the number
because you know what the you know what
the number is
just like you know what the double six
is you know oh and so they're trying to
find a way
to get to that number using this
algorithm yes
uh
yes and the first one to get the result
and the algorithm will use as input some
of the data that they have on their
block
okay
so they crunch numbers using the data on
their block and they're all trying to
get this result that they all know what
it what the result is so this ledger so
this so this distributed ledger
is
a ledger of
pathways
through the algorithm
you can say that yes may i is that
allowed yes yes yes i don't want to get
over poeticized about it because and
actually because i don't want to liken
this to poetry at all
if you really want to get it it is in
that it makes no sense to me
that way they're the same is that
i've been sitting in class and the
teacher is going what do you think it
means that i'm going you know you tell
me okay well so so so sandra what you're
saying is that the miners
are
to get to borrow terms i'm familiar with
they are printing money
yeah
but it's not printing of course but yeah
digitally printing yeah you can look
look at it that way because the winner
the double six winner the person who
gets that actual result first
is the winner and the prize is
12 and a half bitcoin
okay so they are working for their pay
in a sense okay
all right we got to take our first break
but when we come back i want to know
what the hell nfts are
and and i assume marcia does too and
right after that i think we might have
enough foundation to go to our questions
yes with our patreon members okay
so when we come back more of stark talk
cosmic queries
with dr sandra johnson
star talk cosmic queries this one's
about bitcoin and blockchains and all
that stuff some people know everything
about and everyone else knows nothing
and i think my my new co-host marcia
belski and i are in the same camp and of
course then we have an expert on it uh
sandra johnson uh who's got huge
pedigree in the tech world started
companies got patents
um and you graduated is it summa [ __ ]
laude with highest honors in in and what
was that uh in what subject electrical
and electrical engineering yes southern
university baton rouge louisiana so this
would have been i don't know how old you
are but if you go back enough
electrical engineering was the
department that had computer science in
it and so later on computer science had
its own sort of identity on a campus but
that meant uh you were in at the debate
at the at the
ground floor
front door of that
that that is correct that is correct in
fact uh my phd
is also in electrical engineering at
electrical and computer engineering got
it so that doubles that up right right
so marshall
marshall what's your phd in oh well
i got my undergrad in sociology so uh
no that's good if you're gonna be a
comedian you need to know that sociology
oh my god exactly all the material on
the stand up floor is there it's just
sociology exactly yeah but i
you know i am so lost on the engineering
stuff and it's like but it's fascinating
to me because
yeah but i it makes me feel better that
you also don't know
what she's talking about you're basking
in my ignorance why is that no you
should feel sad for me
no
i'm like because then it's like i lisa i
know it's not just my intelligence
overall it's like we're all just you
know
it's it's just a new field that a lot of
us don't know about and but it's
fascinating it really is it's crazy
because people talk about it so much
online they do people just
online chatter so sandra tell me what
are nfts okay so uh crypto
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
okay
uh and the the literally thousands of
cryptocurrencies bitcoin right uh and
and those
cryptos
are interchangeable that is you can buy
and you can use these
uh crypto uh crypto
to buy or sell goods and services
uh in uh and cryptos are what's called
fungible
uh that is you can interchange them uh
nft
is a non-fungible token that is
something that you cannot
you know exchange it's a very unique
unit of data you can
uh
compare it to liken it to like a deed on
a house right there's only one d for the
house right it's not interchangeable
well an nft or non-fungible token is
very similar uh to that
uh it basically has two parts to it this
is all electronic all digital
uh it usually has a digital asset
okay
uh and that digital digital asset
associated with it that digital asset
has a certain value you know it's like a
piece of artwork for example uh so an
nft is a unique unit of data uh that
that
leverages technology to enable this
digital asset
to be placed on the blockchain
and it can be bought and sold
on the blockchain in the open
marketplace
in the open marketplace okay so what
you're saying is this is
so you turn physical objects
like i if i own a picasso
then i have that picasso and you don't
and if you want to buy it you come to me
and pay money for it but that's that's a
physical object made of canvas and paint
and you're telling me you have your
there is this world out there now
of digital assets
that are the am digital analog to my
physical thing that i have a possession
of uh you can think of it that way it's
not quite
because the legal it's so new bleeding
edge
that the the legal
the the legal focus has not kept up
but just for our discussion purposes you
can view it as that okay so if you dumb
it down enough we can think of it that
way
did i hear her right marcia that's what
she just said yeah yeah i'm thinking
nfts need better pr because like that
what you said makes sense to me where
it's a token
of like because what people on the
internet think it is is people paying
thousands of dollars for a photo of an
ape that you could google and it doesn't
make sense to anybody you know what i
mean but but your explanation as a part
of these other two things
that makes sense so it's like i think we
just need better
pr out there explaining it to people
so marcia why don't we go to our uh
patreon uh questions right now because
there may be enough foundation there so
let's check it out and tell me like
their names and if they say where
they're from i always want to know that
too
okay absolutely yeah let's start with
this one because you were talking about
working at ibm
um so this is from
yelmer um vonderweich
which uh looks like a scandinavian name
and it says hello sandra neal i'm
working in finance and my girlfriend is
a blockchain developer at ibm
most of the blockchain talk is about
cryptocurrencies and nfts but the
technology offers a lot more solutions
that will change our lives we would love
to hear from dr johnson about how
digital identity applications work on
the blockchain and how they will impact
our lives ooh
there's a sociological question in a way
yeah yes this is all very sociological
swipe yeah yeah yeah so sandra this is
you know to just live within
you know within the ledgers of tech
geniuses or does this have real world
consequences oh absolutely absolutely uh
i i believe blockchain technology will
change
uh the way humans interact
uh long term
right now there's a lot of hype but i
think moving forward in time so to to
more or less answer the question i'll
give you an example for example an
example in supply chain you know you you
you're a manufacturing company you
manufacture something and you want to
ship it somewhere right you can actually
use blockchain
uh
and put on the blockchain
when it was manufactured
uh
where it's going
uh and who's gonna pick it up
uh all of the details of that you can
you can write a program if you will
that's called a smart contract
that gives you all of the details from a
to b
uh and then once you
finish that digit and put it on the
truck that automatically starts a chain
of events
that now many times is manual stuff get
lost you don't know where it is
but if it's on a blockchain you know
exactly where it is at all times from
putting it on the ship from the ship
reaching its destination from it going
from the ship to another truck and from
the truck to the the plane sandra sandra
fedex does that for me
is that a blockchain i know where my
package is i know when it got i know
when the label was created i know
who signed for it but if that got
disrupted it sounds like this could be
could maybe fill in some of those
gaps because we're seeing all these
problems like that's interesting because
it works outside of those like
i still don't get it but i'm starting to
absolutely
you're getting it
thank you professor
you know even with fedex fedex as
partners they sh
they they may have their own separate
databases storing information with
blockchain everything is there
everyone can go there
and find out at the same time where
everything is
uh nothing should be lost
and you know with fedex you lose things
okay and all digital because a lot of
companies i've worked for are not all
digital
right
oh yeah okay so so
so
um
okay so that
that blockchain
is not currency that's a blockchain of
information
yes
that's why i remember i said initially
blockchain is the foundation it's a
general concept right
currency is is different
right okay so do you foresee a day in
the not so different future where all
information transactions happen on
blockchains
well the overwhelming majority
wow okay yes
yes i mean think about if you're buying
a house for example you know
yeah you know you have to make sure that
the owner is the owner
you know and you pay somebody to do that
a title search
blockchain you don't have to do that
it's going to all be there for example
okay that's that's one example so
and if you could just take that little
thought and kind of extrapolate it to
look at how we do things now and how we
can do it if we had this centralized
place where everything is placed
nothing is modified and you can you have
access to it could there be a comedic
blockchain where they put funny jokes on
it and then everybody
you'll know you'll laugh that you can
never delete you can never do it no
thank you
but think about this if you have an
uh nft associated with your joke
that if other people use it
you can get paid for it this is what
everybody has been talking about this is
the first time i heard about nfts was
somebody advised me
to create an nft from some of my
material and i was like i have no idea
what you're talking about but thank you
so much for
suggesting that but people have made
thousands i know some comedian made like
thousands of dollars doing that
basically and i don't know how and i
don't know who but people have made
millions of dollars particularly last
year on this
which is so for that that's like i take
a video of a set and i don't want to
release it
right
is you getting up with the microphone
and then sitting down and everything you
did between those was a set correct
that's right but so then it's like the
the nft would be the video itself that
somebody then privately purchases so
that they own that set that i did
yes but they don't own the material they
just own
that video which might be valuable if
someone were like hugely famous or like
if it were like you know
like
somebody huge like if amy schumer did a
set that wasn't released and then
somebody
privately marcia i think you're just
about ready to teach the class
[Music]
but that that is
absolutely correct and i'll give you
some examples of some recent nfts
uh major league baseball imagine
baseball cards right
they've done that uh made thousands of
dollars off of that um
a year ago december 2020 a 15 year old
teenager
you know
uh learned about this thing called nft
uh he's an artist
so he worked to put his artwork on uh
create an nft and and sell it on an
exchange uh and as of december 2021 just
last month
he's made over a million dollars
wow see
that's where understanding this stuff
would be so
valuable
okay
by the way just just for fun melania
trump's eyes
her eyes
has also been uh created as an artwork
that she sold as an nft online last
month
wow
okay so so can someone hack into the
blockchain and change what everyone is
thinking is permanent
uh it is highly unlikely that that will
happen i will never say never mm-hmm you
just did it but
that's that's why i said
but it's highly unlikely
uh
but it's highly unlikely it's very
difficult to do well it's difficult now
but i mean you know
with quantum computing
you can always change your algorithms to
make it more difficult yeah okay
all right so it's it's you know it's a
catch-22
oh you have to explain catch-22 to
marcia
[Laughter]
i'll give you that one i'll give you
that so they taught us how to read just
nothing else
we've got time for one more question
before we take our second break so what
do you have marcia okay great yeah this
one was interesting to me um so this is
from richard l sanders
um and it says
once all bitcoin has been discovered
what will incentivize anybody to keep
auditing the blockchain if they know
doing so will not result in discovering
any bitcoin
ooh
i like that question if i like it so
much we're gonna take a break and we'll
pick it up at the end of that break see
what i did there that's it
so anyway when we come back more with dr
johnson and my co-host comedian marcia
belski on star talk cosmic curry all
about bitcoin blockchain and
non-fungible
tokens for tickets yes
non-fungible toads
on star talk
so we're back star talk third and final
segment cosmic queries all about
blockchain and bitcoin we've got sandra
johnson here who's a one of the world's
experts on this subject and been at
computing
forever
uh sandra how do people find you are you
on social media or you have i am on
social media yes what do they call you
there
no sorry what do you call yourself
doctor doctor
dr sandra kj
dr sanders dr sandra kj
dr sandra kj i love it and how about you
marcia how are we going to find you
i'm at marsha belski on twitter
m-a-r-c-i-a
um i also have a tick-tock that same
name and then instagram it's marcia skye
s-k-y marcia skye very nice very nice
and marcia you you made headlines for
this song about a hundred tampons that's
just a weird topic to title a song and
an album with because you're also a
musician and
and i i'm asking i'm curious because i
knew it has something to do with space
but i don't see
i know
that that's true but i don't know why so
could you please explain
so the story is um the song is about the
first american woman they ever sent to
space named sally ride they tried to
give her a hundred tampons to take with
her for a one week mission
and
the story is so she technically never
officially took them with her but um
they they gave her a bag of 100 tampons
tied together by the strings is how this
is from her an oral history i believe
and they basically said
is a hundred the right number of course
how else would you connect tampons
that's the obvious way to do that of
course and see the song is sort of about
how even even our rocket scientists
might be a little blind when it comes to
the lives of women and
um just about how funny it is because
nasa you know obviously is still pretty
um a male
uh dominated industry and um although
there's a lot more women
um than there was at the time even and
um they also designed her a makeup kit
to take with her to space because they
figured that she would want aliens
exactly gotta look pretty for them and
she basically said no thank you
um
and so yeah i wrote a song about how you
know remember when nasa sent a woman to
space for
six days and they tried to give her 100
tampons or in my song i say they gave
her 100 tampons because she never
officially took them but in her oral
history they did they did try and give
them to her
and they said is 100 the right number
and she said that would not be the right
number and they're like right because
it's
too much right
so i thought that was a great story
sandra
speaking of space and
alien encounters where
where apparently sally doesn't need
makeup
could blockchain be
the basis of a
currency
uh interplanetary intergalactic currency
sure
just like it could be the that black
chain the actual crypto oh sorry yes
cryptocurrencies yes just like it could
be a
basis for a global currency yes
so we'll start there how the aliens
study us yeah and by the way marsha
actually you can make your song and nft
yes okay
great i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
message you about how to do that let's
give you 50
okay
so marcia just before we hit the break
there was a great question why don't you
just read that real quick again
absolutely so this is from richard l
sanders and he said once all bitcoin has
been discovered what will incentivize
anybody to keep auditing the blockchain
if they know doing so will not result in
discovering any bitcoin
so
you are assuming that that bitcoin
exists to be discovered
i think so that's what it sounds like
bitcoin is
created
uh to give
uh uh to award a winner which is a
little different it's not like it exists
uh and then you
you know you get your little picks like
a minor and go find it
it's not like an easter egg hunt is what
you're saying right right right so so
it's created when we have a new block
right now there is a limit to the number
of bitcoins that will eventually be
created but it's not like it exists
somewhere hiding and you're going you
you're going out to look for it right so
it's just
you keep
at trying to get that next block on the
blockchain and when you get it you get
the bitcoin
so you said there are thousands of
currencies
such as bitcoin so isn't it and is there
any limit could there be a billion
currencies and at that point there is no
currency it's just what is that that is
correct that
that well just like when they're not
thousands of currencies but just like
there are different currencies what's
called fiat currencies that is what we
know paper dollars for example is a fiat
there are different types of currencies
now there are also different type of
types of crypto currencies
uh thousands actually over 10 000 right
now right so obviously you know it's
going to be difficult to have a global
currency with greater than ten thousand
right well that's one of the issues
um
this is still bleeding edge so i think
moving forward in time that number will
dwindle down
uh for the most part even now most
cryptocurrencies
are not used to buy things
people just invest in it right yes you
use crypto to buy nfts it's probably the
most popular way
crypto itself is used to purchase things
now to buy nfts well that makes sense
because it's the same species right yeah
right right right so but moving forward
in time there will come a time where we
will use crypto to just buy goods and
services that we that we buy normally
now using fiat
all right
like i want to buy an apple
and then they tell me how much you can
use a crypto to buy at some point in the
future not now there are some businesses
uh that allow you to uh purchase their
goods and services
uh using crypto
and there's a website that you can go to
that lists the different businesses uh
and then the type of cryptocurrency that
they accept
i can really relate emotionally to the
people that were like living when
dollars took over for gold and they're
like i'm just gonna keep my gold thank
you
yeah here's this piece of paper oh my
gosh yeah and it's like why would i
trust that and now we're going from
paper to digital and i think people are
feeling a similar way that's spooky
you're spooking
give me some more questions let's see
how many we can fit in this segment go
yes so this question i think is
interesting because there were a few
questions about the environmental impact
of cryptocurrency so i'm sure you're
asked a lot so this says hello dr
johnson and dr tyson
how can someone invest in crypto
ethically it's something i've been
interested in but the environmental
implications of the incredibly high
energy use have kept me from getting
involved and that is from chris plotz
why why why does this take energy at all
is it just turning on your computer is
it just
the
computer computational power it takes a
lot of computational power the computer
crunching the numbers is a very very uh
computationally intensive which means it
takes a lot of electricity
to actually
get the double six in other words
right uh and and and for some uh
blockchains you know it takes the amount
of power the equivalent of a small city
okay
just to do one transaction
so it is computationally intensive
particularly the bitcoin
and the second most uh popular
uh
blockchain ethereum uh with its ether
cryptocurrency
very very
massive amounts of electricity right so
you gotta admit that's a cooler name
marshall you gotta admit right ethereum
yeah
way better than bitcoin
i think so
now there are other
uh blockchains
that uh
have a different type of methodology
to why that who the next who the winner
is for example uh that are not as
computationally
intensive
um even ethereum
uh
although they've been talking about this
for quite a while it's moving towards
another
uh type of algorithm that is not as
uh computationally intensive therefore
it will not take as much electricity
they're not there yet they've been
talking about it for a couple of years
so there are alternatives to bitcoin and
ethereum that are not as uh
intensive in terms of the amount of
power so if you want to be a green
crypto
currency you create a solar panel farm
that just drives the computer that
that i mean you it's it's a solvable
problem it seems yes because not all
energy on earth comes from coal right
yes absolutely yeah absolutely that's
that's another option so it need to be
sustainable
yeah yeah okay marcia keep it going
okay so this um
you were talking about how
why this work really inspired you early
on um so i think this is interesting it
says this is from lydia from the
netherlands she says dear everyone so
that includes me i guess
as someone who has almost no knowledge
about cryptocurrency and nfts it scares
me that these things are growing and
that paper money would be something for
the poor people
why does crypto have so much preference
by so many people and how can i prepare
myself for the future
i relate to that yeah i love that
question very important once again a
sociological question those are the ones
i'm drawn to yeah well the haves be
crypto rich and the poor's be
uh paper poor you know what what what
yeah how's it what's this gonna look
like um
so whatever it is we'll blame you right
now no no no it's not me i just know
about it
i don't create it i don't know
i just know about it i love it hey okay
uh but anyway some cryptocurrencies are
very expensive
you know for example bitcoin last fall
november
got up to almost 69 000
it's gone down now to about 37 000 or so
per unit whatever that
per cryptocurrency yes
uh so that's very expensive but then
there are others that cost much less
okay so in terms of cost it really
depends upon the actual cryptocurrency
you know my view is that as we move
forward and it becomes used more
prevalently uh the cost will go down
uh so to that will that will address the
issue of of course um which i i have a
philosophical question what does it mean
for cryptocurrency to cost anything
because it's right now
unlike the dollar right you can actually
invest
uh in cryptocurrency wait wait wait but
i i will buy
cryptocurrency with my american dollars
you can do that yes
or i can buy cryptocurrency with some
other cryptocurrency
um you can do that as well yeah okay so
if i buy with american dollars the
person who had the crypto
now has my dollars and i have their
cryptocurrency in exchange for it that's
correct but there might be a day where
everybody only ever wants cryptocurrency
to acquire other cryptocurrency and so
that no one will want the dollar
and that will drop down the value of the
dollar won't it
i'm not an economist okay
cause i you know if you go down the
street the homeless person you hand them
some
coins or a few dollars no i want
cryptocurrency
right well you know the mayor of new
york the new mayor you know said he
wants to be paid in crypto what
people are kind of roasting him alive
for it to be honest oh right
because they because also because when
the bitcoin is down
people were like well now this is like
what eric adams is paycheck's actually
going to be this percent less than it
would have been
and i think people are just so it's it
has such a
like reputation as being for in my mind
like white tech bros that i don't think
people understand that there's like
different
people and like like incentives working
on this because i think a lot of the
fear is like these are just the top one
percent
making a new set of money for themselves
but hearing you talk it seems like
something
so much different than that
yeah right right now because it's still
new
uh most of the people who buy crypto
bitcoin etho and others
they're expecting as an
yeah yeah they are speculating so it's
just the wild west it might settle
somewhere four years ago i mean even
though we thought it was high then it
was like 20 000 right
so now it's gotten up to almost 75 so
you know it's speculation yeah yeah that
makes sense
i don't know if you have to have a
certain bravery to like or a certain
comfort level to to do that right i
don't know if we have time for another
question but i do since i'm host i can
make time for my own question so sandra
so
i you know i've been in computing
for a while i mean i
you know since high school at least
and and i'm old so but i've seen the
power of computing grow i've seen what
and particularly in astrophysics there
are categories of problems that are
intractable at any given moment
with what the computing power is at that
moment
and so we say well we need this extra
power and then so new problems get
solved as computers get faster and more
efficient and as algorithms get more
clever
so
why lock anything into
why lock an economy
into something that's fundamentally
seems to me
about the power of computing at that
moment
because if in the future computers are a
billion times more powerful what you're
telling me is what takes all power of a
city i mean look at the computers from
1958 there were entire rooms to just to
do four function math
so so so why lock into something that
seems to me to be something
on a moving platform you know on a
to something on a is a moving target
for the power that computers will bring
to that problem
okay so let's go back to the whole how
much power it takes to uh
to uh complete a transaction you know uh
much of that is because you have minors
remember them all over the world so as
we move forward in time more and more
meyers miners are competing it's taking
significantly more computing power
because of the bottleneck right so as
you increase the power of the computer
that reduces the power
to actually do the mining yes so
increasing the computational
power of the computer
helps that issue
i i get that but then now i have a
computer that just finds every single
bitcoin there is and i can do it this
afternoon and then i'm the richest
person in the world so i don't think
we'll get to the point where
you know it's um
um
the computer becomes more computational
computationally intensive more miners
are added and you know it's sort of a
loop it keeps going
more miners more power needed you need
more miners more power needed etc okay
so marsha the the comedy club owner who
offers you bitcoin are you gonna say no
i want ethereum
[Laughter]
i would the problem is like i would say
no just because
i still
it's it's tough though because it's like
i take cash and stuff even though i
probably would still need to hire an
accountant but it's like yeah i don't
feel that i'm on the the bleeding edge
enough
to
to be able to do it but then it's you
know
i think it's like anything too it's like
i've heard stories of well there was
this one guy i really trusted
he got me into bitcoin it turned out to
be like a bad investment and then i've
heard stories of the exact opposite so i
think that's what keeps people afraid is
the inconsistency of the
um
what's it called the reward
but so it's like for me i still want my
cash because i'm not at the point in my
life where i can risk my paycheck being
two thousand dollars less than it was
supposed to but i can understand why
somebody who is in the financial
position to do that
would do that because it could
potentially have a great bigger
future payoff not just for them for
their kids to i think it's like
diversifying your portfolio in a way it
would make sense to have stocks have
crypto and also have
cash but you need to be at a certain
level you have to confess though you've
come a long way not you you but
you as as representative person in this
conversation you've come a long way from
the days when you might have just
accepted a chicken for payment right yes
yeah exactly we've that's that's like it
feels so scary to me but i'm seeing it
in my head like that where it's i bet
it's the same that people felt when we
went from you know cowrie shells to gold
from gold to
whatever but right not for me not yet
but i am but i
i'm interested by it all right well
sandra we're going to have to do we this
is this topic is ever
ever growing and
uh we might have to do this again do a
part two
and you have to give us buying tips
oh yeah okay we can do that that'll be
the most popular star talk episode ever
all right i made a million dollars
all right
you have the richest fan base
i must say i'm not a professional at
this so you know you buy your
journalists
there is one thing i do want to point
out though marcia and neil you know kind
of alluded to uh the volatility of
cryptos but that there are some uh some
some uh tokens if you will
cryptocurrencies that are stable they're
called stable coins
uh and and these are
associated with uh a physical
entity for example there's a usd coin
it's a crypto but it's backed by the us
dollar right dollar for dollar
uh the same thing with gold or diamonds
so there are stable cryptocurrencies
that you can
actually hold and many people they they
have these staple coins and then they
they use them to buy the volatile
cryptos and they go back and forth right
you know what this sounds like to me
sandra when apple first came out with
their macintosh and they had the
windowing system
um
if you had a file and you wanted to save
it together with other files you put
them in this icon on your screen that
looked like a folder
yes
it's not an actual folder
it's a virtual folder and then you throw
something away there's a little trash
can so they they try to emulate your
office environment
into the space that you're operating on
for comfort levels right i guess yes and
and i i make special note that in recent
macintosh updates of their system their
icon for their mail which used to be a
stamp
is now just an envelope both of those
are still kind of archaic but especially
a stamp because the you know generation
q or what's the latest z whatever
they've never licked a stamp and they're
locked
[Laughter]
so like what is that yeah
so anyway we got to call it quits there
great to have you both on star talk both
for their first time new newbies
very very excellent i love seeing some
new new blood
flowing
through the rivers of
scientific enlightenment
okay gotta go now
thank you so much for having me this was
so fun and it was such it was so great
to hear you talk dr johnson thank you
yeah it's been a pleasure boston call me
about the song now all right well 100
tampons don't miss the hunter tampons
nft be on the lookout there's a youtube
of her singing it so this has been star
talk cosmic queries uh all about
cryptocurrency with dr sandra johnson
i'm neil degrasse tyson here your
personal astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
you